it's an image that spread around the
world like wildfire a once-in-a-lifetime
moment for an ass madam we a refugee
from Syria standing alongside the most
powerful woman in the world at that time
he was new to Berlin all alone but
brimming with confidence thanks in no
small part to the Chancellor today he
feels disillusioned his patience wearing
thin as he waits for his Asylum stages
to be approved the hot Bonneville is
will always see I'm still afraid that my
asylum application will be rejected or
new laws and Germany will be adopted one
such law could be a deportation Act
which would deport me to another country
even though I've been enrolled in a
German course for some time an ass
managed to find a home with a German
family until his parents and siblings
can make it to Germany uncle may of will
take care of an us as if he were one of
her own children and he see it as it
breaks my heart to see that routes are
being blocked for Refugees like what's
happening in E Domini it makes me mad
and I could just scream it's ok I would
like to go there and say open the gate
mangos math Alf and as also once the
border fences torn down across Europe
Bettina's friends know that is unlikely
worship at me again if I see the
Chancellor again i'll take another
selfie with her and ask her to bring my
family to safety here in Germany that
way we can build a future together in
this country suburb havasu although the
weight is wearing him down and I'll
still believes in the German Chancellor